Georgia helped give Democrats a senate
majority two years ago but it took a
runoff to get there State officials say
it looks like we're headed for another
runoff this year as neither Democratic
senator Rafael Warnock and Republican
Challenger Herschel Walker have hit the
50 threshold to win outright Nicole
Killian is outside Atlanta Nicole good
morning so what comes next
yeah good morning to you Nate well if
this goes to a runoff then there will be
another election day in December a top
official with the Secretary of State's
office tweeted overnight we feel it is
safe to say that there will be a runoff
for the U.S Senate here in Georgia
slated for December 6. sources close to
Republican her show Walkers campaign
tell CBS news that they are waiting for
outstanding votes in several counties
north of Atlanta still Democratic
senator Rafael Warnock says he is
feeling good about the outcome here's a
look at why this race is Razor thin this
all comes down to the economy CBS News
exit poll showed inflation outpaced
abortion in terms of importance to GOP
voters but it was abortion rights that
was on the minds of Democrats and that
was one of many issues that defined the
governor's race with Republican
incumbent Brian Kemp defeating Democrat
Stacey Abrams in a rematch to win a
second term of course Abrams helped
Democrats flip the state in 2020 with
President Biden winning by a very narrow
margin and of course again in 2021 when
Democrats picked up two Senate seats
coincidentally in a runoff Gail
all right Nicole thank you very much